i'm a fan of this man's work um
city on a hill um which we've had we've
had um
kevin bacon here right yeah um and we
talk about
uh that show i can't wait for it to come
back he's in it
remote drop movie for me michael clayton
is a remote drop film for me great film
i could make a case even
it's my it's the best george clooney
moving out there
which is i would entertain a pop culture
hot take i would entertain that
okay but in the for the purposes of this
being a sports show as well as an
entertainment show
and the fact that this gent just looped
a couple of rounds at wing foot side of
the
united states open and the fact that he
played
easily outside of i guess maybe bagger
vance the most famous caddy in the
history of film
[Laughter]
wearing his bushwood country club hath
while looping where he looped as a young
man himself
the actor who played danny noonan from
caddyshack michael o'keefe
here on the rich housing show how's that
for an intro michael
oh my god i'm going to memorize it and
put it on a card to hand a friend
i mean it was great seeing you out there
with the bushwood country club lid
walk me through how you got how you were
well i know i know you wrote
an article for golf.com essentially
saying that you
you're up for lupin this week and you
got you got on a bag so walk me through
all this michael
well you know it was just kind of a lark
you know it's the 40th anniversary of
the film being released and golf.com
said do you want to write something and
i thought
you know i do know the wing foot i did
train there when i
when i was getting ready to make
caddyshack i spent about six weeks up
there with the pro at the time
tom neaporti his son joe and their
assistant dave schultz and
they just kind of helped me get my swing
together and so i felt like you know
what have i got to lose you know and i
i also thought my chances were about as
likely as carl spakler
winning the mate of the masters right
and then mike breed the teaching pro
who's got a
show on sirius radio asked me for an
interview and i said sure and afterwards
he said hey listen
if you really want this to happen i
think i've got somebody for you so you
gotta let me know if you're for real and
i was like
yeah and you know then as soon as we
hung up
he got a hold of danny balin and danny
got you know involved and
put me on his back and so i just did two
days
you know carrying a pro bag over at the
wing foot which was really quite a
journey i got to tell you
now i mean a balanced story is amazing
he's the head pro
at fresh meadow country club in lake
success new york
and because of the pandemic um
the pga championship as well as the us
open said we're just gonna take the top
three
from the uh from the list of the pga
club pro player of the year list of last
year
and he got in both tournaments because
of it and that's how you wound up
you wound up with him looping it's a
fluke year
i think one of the reasons i think this
story took off and got
legs was because there's this you know
we've all been quarantined for six
months and
sports are just kind of coming back but
you know the
the lack of the gallery and golf you
know the lack of fans and
the other sports i think is daunting for
people and they're looking for some kind
of
you know way to get inspired the way we
do when we watch sports and this story
i think is somewhat connected to stories
like francis we met
winning the 1913 u.s open as a caddy at
the brookline country club
greg pooga the great caddy from east l.a
who caddies up at bel air getting into
the masters in 2000
you know after winning the mid amps
those types of stories i think sparked
the imagination and i think
caddyshack and danny noonan just kind of
ticked that box for people
it did and then just seeing you caddying
um
there so so you when you said that you
spent time there did you
did were you a caddie at wingfoot before
yeah i
i i carried there when i was in high
school in the summer and 71 and 72
my dad was friends with gene hayden who
was a legendary caddy master at the time
the pro at the time was claude harmon
and his three sons craig and billy and
butch were you know
billy was a teenager and craig and butch
were in their 20s they used to go out
just
bomb the courses there and the first
hole on the east course is right next to
the caddyshack so anytime the harmon
boys were going out there
we'd all just sort of like peter kind of
sneak out at the caddyshack trying not
to get in trouble and watch them tee off
just because they were such
legendary hitters wow and then their the
practice
uh green is also right there by the
caddyshack and there were these sand
traps there
and their dad claude harmon used to give
lessons and to this day it's indelibly
etched in my mind
watching claude harmon give a sand trap
lesson and he had this kind of
magic feel so yesterday when we went off
on the front nine
there's a guy at the starters booth and
he looks at me and i look at him and he
goes
how you doing i'm one of the harman boys
and i said are you billy harmon
and she said yeah and i said man it has
been about
50 years no way senior
it was unbelievable and there he was
and he had he never seen caddyshack
though michael of course he had but we
hadn't seen each other in 50 years
the last time i saw him he was a 19 year
old kid
and there he was you know probably in
his early 70s and he
turns out was his close friends with my
brother billy
who's a former president of wingfoot and
you know my brother billy's actually
like a civilian and an adult with a job
you know
so he can uh he can afford to join wing
foot you know
so now but so so i've got a few
questions for you here
michael um uh michael o'keefe the actor
joining me here after he just looped for
danny ballon who's got a great story
again
there's a danny on the right and then uh
danny noonan on the left
um right there on our screen um
so when you said there was a caddyshack
that you were part of at wingfoot in uh
1971 tell me wingfoot was in fact
uh being run by a judge named smails
please tell me that
did that actually happen no i wish i
wish there were some legendary
characters
some of the more memorable characters
were the caddies like there was a great
caddy named
tasty and uh he was
hilarious and he was one of these guys
that
you know had a penchant for wine and was
always getting in trouble with the caddy
master gene hayden
and gene even when you got like even
good news from gene would put the fear
of god in you
because he'd call out your name when you
got olivia michael okay
get j.j gagliard and go down to one one
one west
you'd be like oh my god i think i just
had a heart attack all right
and then the guy who ran the club room
was named mo
and you could not understand a word he
said
he talked so fast and it was so kind of
muted in some kind of
i don't know what he would you come in
and say mo i need jj
[Music]
something like let me get that bag for
you but
nobody really knew what he was saying so
we all just kind of nodded and said okay
tasty would get into a fight with gene
and if you got into trouble with gene
he'd send you down the hill
they say go down the hill oh my god
it's at the time and and i imagine that
so then
the groundskeeper did not have uh in his
house uh kentucky bluegrass and
california said samia together that did
not happen as well is what you're saying
well it was the 70s you know
it might have been that way back then by
the way i literally could do this for
another hour uh
with you michael o'keefe but i i gotta
get some stories from the set
40 years ago um at the time
um give give me your favorite story
whether it involves rodney dangerfield
or
ted knight who i think is a comic genius
um
anything anything that was ad-libbed
with chevy chase uh
bill murray obviously give me your
favorite story you know bill and
bill was just taking off he had just
booked saturday night live
meatballs was in the can it wasn't even
out yet it was only his second film
none of his dialogue was written so when
he showed up and he did that cinderella
story about winning the masters
or looping for the dalai lama they wrote
that he wrote it was harold's kind of
you know help editing right there on the
spot you know so
his genius was evident even back then
chevy was our had already done fletch
what i loved which i loved and i also
saw him do national lampoon's lemmings
uh
down in the eastville or the west
village when i was a kid which was
an amazing uh knockoff of woodstock that
national lampoon did
ted like you i was a huge fan of his
from mary tyler moore and randy
dangerfield was my dad's favorite
community we used to watch him on ed
sullivan
first day on the set i go and i say hi
to rodney and i smile and say hello and
he goes
oh kid your teeth are terrible my my
nephew's a dentist maybe i can set you
up with him
and i'm like oh thanks rodney that's
great let's go on camera together
so he kind of reads me he goes ah don't
worry about it he goes florida huh
it's like a sauna with gnats
[Laughter]
he's on always on
uh any so did anything else ad-libbed
from you
or from uh oh you know that that famous
you know do you do drugs danny every day
that was a
you know that's made it onto a few
t-shirts that was definitely an ad-lib
okay uh most of it chevy's like when
chevy did that knock off of the six
million dollar
man sound when he was making all those
putts
i i didn't even know what he was gonna
do until he started doing it so i just
you know was all i could do to keep a
straight face
you know and the great thing on that
film was watching harold and
remus our director and doug kenney
realized that
in chevy and bill and ted and rodney
they had a kind of modern marx brothers
thing going on
you know which of course made me geppo
marks the you know the unfunny
you know one that could help with the
bags um
so they just you know rocked that thing
as far as they could and that's why we
have the film we have they threw out the
script about nine or ten days into the
shooting
and then they just let these guys really
just roll and
harold was really really adept at kind
of
wrangling them into a shape that would
work and you know 40 years later we've
got what we've got
what do you mean you threw out the
script they just said you know
obviously keeping the spine of it but
you know
again the scene with you and ted knight
um
where he's trying to ask if you stand
for goodness or badness
i mean that's one of my favorite scenes
involving you in this film
uh michael i mean you're laughing about
it now
40 years later how did you keep a street
face straight face when he's asking you
you know about mow my lawn and making
that noise and stuff like that i used to
keep
i used to keep a safety pin in my pocket
and if if
if i thought i was going to laugh i'd
pop it and stab myself from the fog are
you serious
of course not but that sounds good it
sounds great
i'm gullible when it comes to this sort
of stuff
but i mean and you know the other great
thing about the wing foot you know is
that i trained for the film there
you know i went back there and trained
with joe neaporty and tom neaporty as
dad
and i was out on the range every day for
six weeks and you know one of the things
one of the things i wanted to mention on
your show
there's a great gofundme page called
richie richie's gift which is the thing
that's set up to support the caddies
during the pandemic at wingfield because
like everybody else
you know they've been suffering and out
of work and now that the open's there
you know none of the members are taking
the local caddies out so
anybody who wants to contribute can go
to that gofundme page richie's gift to
just throw a couple of bucks their way
and i'm sure they'd appreciate it
richie's gift
uh at gofundme i mean yeah i mean that
is
obviously uh a worthy
worthy um visit to gofundme to make sure
that uh
put a little bit extra scratch in these
guys pockets um
michael um thanks for the call and it
was just great seeing you how how
how old is that uh bushwood country club
hat that you got
on your own it's not 40 years old my
brother lost the original i think in a
bar in north carolina
come on come on in 1979 i'm sure if that
ever
surfaced we could have an auction for
that come on but uh
i want to tell you man i have a new
respect for the professional caddies out
there because
there's not one part of my body that's
not sore except my teeth
yeah i mean is is uh is danny ready did
you get him ready
uh because oh man you know his caddy
he's a great guy named mark mondeblot
and they were they were uh
the track brothers at penn state so they
got a real
really good relationship and i think you
know i think he's got a shot i think
he's going to make the cut you know and
and uh i'm really pulling for him it'll
be a great story but
you know that course is set up with so
so uh
daunting steve robideaux is the name of
the superintendent
and i'll tell you the rough is like
dante's hell
and the the greens the front of those
greens are like ski slopes
right anybody that doesn't get it about
seven or eight yards onto the front of
all those greens is going to be you know
getting to their ball a lot sooner than
they'd like coming off the tee if you
know what i mean i do know that
i know and i'm just knowing that uh you
know you could use a rest i hope the
pool was open for you yesterday
well they let me use the pond
it's just honestly i could literally go
on and on like this and i know you must
you must hear this stuff uh absolutely
all the time
so what do you think man for you for you
rich you know i'm a huge fan i'm
right back for years and i'm happy to
talk to you guys i had the time of my
life
and i have danny bailey and mike breed
to thank for it because mike's the guy
that hooked us up yeah excellent
uh and again rich what's the name of the
gofundme page again
it's called richie's gift on gofundme
richie's gift
when is city on a hill coming back
what's what's going on
we just got noticed they're going to
start filming again you know so i'm
hoping soon
i love that show kevin bacon is a you
know legendary actor and he's great on
the show and aldous hodge is
his co-star boy he's really something
he's been here talking about
too and uh and again i really mean it
michael clayton for me is a remote drop
movie that movie i i think that movie is
perfect
i i don't i don't find a a bad frame
from that i would have to you know i
would support your argument that it's
the best thing clooney has on film
because
it's a standout performance from him and
i think it's
one of the reasons why is because it was
written so well by the writer director
tony gilroy and it was his first
directing job
and he knocked that thing out of the
park and he had to direct not only
clooney who's no slouch as a director
but one of our great american directors
that's right and that was
i think that was the last film he was in
actually before he passed away
that's right and then we lost him you
know and you were
you were in a couple scenes with him too
that had to be something else for you in
your car oh man it was the treat of a
lifetime you know it's uh
i you know it's a it's a job i always
like talking about
thanks for the call uh it was great
seeing you out there let's
let's do this again let's uh let's keep
doing this i'm hoping to get a bag and
the master
is rich
i don't know man i mean that might be a
very tall order um
you know you might have to get the pond
in that one to use the phrase
you know it could happen i know the
greens break towards ray's creek come on
give me a shot
okay i think behind race creek there is
a lumber yard so let's be careful
okay take care of yourself man thanks
for the call take care
what a blast what a fun chat hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here